new CBP numbers released yesterday show
that there were more than 156
000 migrant Encounters in January
totaling nearly 875
000 illegals Crossing in 2023 so far and
for Americans thinking of vacationing in
Mexico the state department is issuing
their strongest do not travel warning
saying you should avoid going to Six
States in the country they cite the rise
of crime and kidnappings here to react
as senior editor at the Federalist John
Daniel Davidson John thank you for
joining us this morning on this Warning
by the state department is quite serious
I'm going to tell you the list of other
countries that have a similar warning
from the state department Iran Iraq
North Korea Ukraine Haiti Somalia and
Syria definitely not places that we
would consider Paradise to vacation in
and now Mexico's on that list on what's
Happening to Mexico and and why is it
falling into this category
yeah the simple answer is that Mexico is
being taken over by Massive and Powerful
drug cartels and these cartels have
expanded their operations far beyond
drug trafficking they're involved in
Mass industrial scale extortion and
kidnapping operations migrant smuggling
they're they're involved in major
industries in Mexico they've in some
cases they've taken over state and local
governments these are multinational
criminal syndicates operating inside
what amounts to a failing State we would
never allow let's say
um Syria to be on our Southern border
and collapse into chaos and Anarchy but
that's essentially what's happening uh
in Mexico right now so it's so
interesting and you're absolutely right
it's turning into a narco state is that
the I mean how much of this has to do
with the Biden policies and is that the
the sort of deal they're willing to
accept you know in order to get this
illegal immigration in and open our
borders we're willing to accept a failed
Narco State on our on our Southern order
I think the Biden Administration like a
lot of democrat administration's views
foreign policy through a domestic
politics lens so to them Mass illegal
immigration is just sort of a proxy for
our domestic political squabbles but it
really is a national security problem
this problem goes back a long time in
Mexico
successive administrations have ignored
it and failed to understand it and now
it's getting worse and so the illegal
immigration we see coming in fuels and
funds these cartels they make billions
and billions of dollars off our
immigration policies and off the byte
administration's failure to secure the
Border yeah they're more powerful than
ever you point out they control 35 to 40
percent of Mexican territory I mean it's
just it's frightening they're
interfering with Mexican elections I
mean we worry about big Tech here they
worry about big Tech and cartels
influencing the elections right
that's right in fact the line between
you know the government and the cartels
in many places in in Mexico has become
blurred and almost indistinguishable we
see the most powerful cartel in Mexico
the Sinaloa cartel is aligned with the
ruling Moreno party of President Lopez
obrador and we saw that in the in the
last round of national uh and state
elections in Mexico where Moreno won in
Sinaloa State thanks to the help of the
cartel so there's a real collusion I
know Democrats like to use the word
collusion there's a real collusion
between the Mexican Government and these
cartels and U.S policy makers have got
to wake up to this and get real about
what's really happening on the southern
border yeah you have done amazing
investigation and Reporting on this I
thank you for raising the alarm on it
and as you say it is a national security
issue of the highest order uh John
Daniel Davidson thanks for joining us
this morning
thanks for having me you got it I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis